Period cramps getting you down?
Just chug some oil!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with a new
study about everyone's favorite topic, period
cramps.
And if you're a guy watching this - don't
switch off just yet, because some day - you
WILL have to deal with a girl who has cramps
- and when that day comes, you'll be thanking
yourself for watching this episode.
The Caspian Journal of Internal Medicine published
a study this week, showing that thyme oil
- is a safer and more effective painkiller
for cramps than ibuprofen.
Who knew?
Researchers looked at 84 women with primary
Dysmenorrhea - which is the medical term for
painful menstrual cramps - and separated them
into 3 treatment groups.
The first group, received 200mg of ibuprofen
as well as 25 drops of a placebo essential
oil, at the first onset of cramps.
The second group was treated with 25 drops
of thyme essential oil and a placebo capsule.
And the third group was given both a placebo
capsule and 25 drops of placebo oil.
They were then asked to rate their pain - using
the visual analogue scale - both before the
treatment, and during the treatment - for
two consecutive cycles.
Turns out, the women treated with thyme oil
- experienced slightly more pain relief over
time, than the women taking ibuprofen - both
of which were more effective than the placebo
treatment.
What's more, is that the women taking the
ibuprofen, reported a decrease in pain relief
during their second monthly cycle.
While the thyme oil group, reported even greater
pain relief in the second month of use than
in the first.
Researchers say this is because the body builds
up a tolerance to pharmaceutical drugs, but
not to things like thyme oil - which are recognized
by the body.
So not only does thyme oil provide relief
for longer - it also doesn't carry the same
set of risks as ibuprofen, which can cause
widespread inflammation and other health problems
- even in the short term.
Because of those side effects, people have
begun seeking out more natural methods for
pain relief - and thyme oil in particular,
has been known to relieve both pain and muscle
spasms.
It contains high amounts of Carvacrol - which
is an organic compound that inhibits the growth
of bacteria, and acts as a natural anti-inflammatory.
A similar study conducted in South Korea in
2012, also found that clary sage, marjoram,
cinnamon, ginger, and geranium oil - accompanied
by an abdomen massage - were also more effective
in alleviating menstrual cramps, than a dose
of tylenol.
So the next time it's that "time of the month"
- try dropping some thyme oil into your tea,
instead of popping a pill.
The only caution experts give, is to make
sure you get a good quality, therapeutic grade
oil.
MAN science is amazing - and it gets better
every day.
If you agree, then you ought to check out
IFLS with Elise Andrew, where she explores
all things trending in science.
There are new episodes every week, featuring
fascinating stories related chemistry, health,
astronomy and beyond.
Including stuff
like this.
Guess THEY don't have to worry about menstrual
cramps, huh?
Lucky bastards.
As always if you have questions, comments,
anything you wanna say about this study - leave
em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!